hi everyone i'm jonathan trance and
let's not waste any time today I got
another tactical challenge for you so
let's check it out
alright so in this position it's white
to move see if you can find the best
move I'll give you about 5 to 10 seconds
to see if you can solve it well you can
pause the video for yourself if you want
to take a little bit more time alright
so hopefully you were able to find the
solution the answer is Queen takes h6
check a very powerful move and we can
see it in the following variations if
for example the King just takes the
Queen I hope you can see what white
would play here it's a checkmate in one
move rook to h1 and the game is over and
much more attractive combination happens
however if black decides instead to take
the queen with the pond go ahead again
see hopefully you can find the checkmate
and to here
the answer is Knight to f6 check and
after King h8 rook to g8 a very pretty
finish thank you for watching this video
if you want to see more great chess
content like this please hit the
subscribe button and we'll see you next
time for another tactical challenge